hollande veut du sang il en aura la
phrase est de frigide barjot la porte
parole des opposants au mariage pour
tous c'était en fin de semaine dernière
une phrase qui a été largement commenté
ces derniers jours quant à son impact
sur ses troupes il ne faudra pas
attendre longtemps pour le savoir après
une première manifestation à versailles
le 4 février le collectif manif pour
tous annoncent un nouveau rassemblement
mardi 16 avril à 19 heures devant le
château là devant le mépris du
gouvernement d'entendre le peuple
français et le déni de démocratie que
constitue le passage en force de la loi
taubira pour le mariage et l'adoption
pour les couples de même sexe précisent
les organisateurs
ils étaient entre 15 et 22 milles à
versailles il y a deux mois le projet de
loi a été adopté par le sénat il
retourne mercredi prochain devant
l'assemblée pour une adoption définitive
ce qui nous amène à la phrase du jour la
phrase de cette édition elle est signée
de la conseillère générale des yvelines
et présidente du parti chrétien
démocrate christine boutin la france a
une responsabilité historique qui est
celle des droits de l'homme
invité de radio classique et de public
sénat l'a déclaré une nouvelle fois que
les droits de l'homme était en train de
s'effondrer avant d'ajouter à la france
est très regardée dans le monde il est
bien évident que si ce texte passe ce
sera ensuite dans le monde entier
pendant ce temps jean frédéric poisson
député du parti chrétien démocrate est
également de l'ump dans la 10e
circonscription des yvelines s'est rendu
à paris au commissariat du xviiie
arrondissement vous le voyez sur cette
photo postée sur les réseaux sociaux
c'est afin de soutenir les 70 opposants
interpellés ce matin pour avoir installé
des tentes devant le palais bourbon il
pourrait se voir poursuivies pour non
dispersion après sommations lors d'un
attroupement un délit passible d'un an
de prison et de 15000 euros damende
changer ou partez autre député henri
guaino ump et autres déclarations
toujours sur le même thème il demande au
gouvernement de changer de politique de
méthodes d'attitude ou bien de partir il
a appelé à sur france 2 aujourd'hui les
français à descendre dans la rue le plus
massivement demain après demain dimanche
prochain la situation est grave le
gouvernement sera responsable du mépris
avec lequel il traite une bonne partie
des français at-il con